[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
we're two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time I'm link and I'm
Rett this week at the round table of
demm lighting we are going to be uh
catching up with one another checking in
on how well we're doing with the things
that we said we would be doing in 2024
yeah and not just the things that we
said we would be doing in 2024 just a
couple of weeks ago yeah I.E New Year's
resolutions but we're also going to be
checking in on a
10year prediction going back to a very
old ear biscuit and see how uh how right
we were and how wrong we were and are we
prepared to then make predictions for no
another decade maybe based on the little
bit that I saw maybe we'll get some
confidence from our
success I don't know about that chrisy
told me yesterday she was like you know
what we're like getting ready for bed
we're having our little pre-s Slumber
chat pre-s Slumber chat you know getting
in the bed and um she was like I've
noticed a new habit that you've
developed okay and this is usually this
sounds like it could be a critique it
usually when you start a conversation
like that my response was oh you notice
that I am much more patient that I'm
that's not I'm habitually more
grateful and yeah she made
that and I was like let me let me see if
I can guess what it
is and I immediately thought well is it
related to my New Year's resolution of
which I pretty much only made one and
um but I didn't know how she would see
that as me not using my phone on the
toilet I just wouldn't know how she
would see that as
she would even observe that as a new
what she would call habit are you saying
that because you don't poop in front of
each other um we
can we're free to but we try to avoid it
you know we're we I try to be like
shit's passing in the night kind of a
thing yeah you know shit's passing in
the night you know because I don't keep
the romance a lot I am so jealous of you
and anyone else that has like isolated
to an isolated toilet closet cuz you
have a pony wall yeah I just got a pony
wall that ain't enough man the pony pony
ain't enough to keep everything if you
can still see the head of the pony you
know what the pony's
doing I try to make a pony noise and you
need a pony door you need a a pony room
right I wish I had a pony room uh our
remodel years ago would accommodate a
window in the shower but it would not
accommodate a box around the toilet yeah
it you need more space than you think
you do for that type of thing right but
I didn't think that she would notice
that or call it a
habit and um I said is it is it toilet
related she was like yes oh oh and she
was heated about it and then I I
realized it I was like does it have
something to do with the toilet seat she
was like yes what and it just has been
like over the past week or so my
goodness now that we're back home from
vacation you're leaving the toilet seat
up you never did that before Oh this is
very un out out of character for you
yeah cuz I would in my house on that
toilet I I would also pee sitting down
right and so why do you ever have the
occasion to put the toilet seat up well
my I didn't tell you but my other New
Year's resolution was now I sit on the
toilet with the seat up it's like I go
that that much deeper it's more fun y
want to be closer to the water it's less
flashing no this is a correlation now
when I'm just going to pee in order to
then remove the temptation to keep my
New Year's resolution of not being on my
phone while on the toilet I'm going to
not pee sitting down oh my goodness now
I will say the reason why this feels
like a big big conflict here yeah the
reason why I pee sitting down and that
has been my habit for years is because I
love my toilet and it's just a nice
restful place to sit and just pee and
who knows what else could happen um but
then I get and I get on my phone all
that's been fun right okay you know uh
and also so you would get on your phone
while peeing only because I'm seated
there how long you peeing well we know
you pee for quite a while you did win
the long peeing contest that we had on
GMS it's just that I'm seated and my
phone's there and you know I'm starting
to pee might as well just out of habit I
whip my phone out cuz I'm on the toilet
this is something I've never been
challenged with the other reason I've
done that is because there's no splash
like even if you don't think there is
when you're standing and peeing into a
toilet there's there's a dis dissipation
of Splash that's happening on the floor
and and it's and it in the air it
creates an aerosol of urine and I
haven't loved that but now I'm giving my
butthole the love that it needs by
sitting Less on a toilet seat well there
you go that's also true yeah so I'm
standing to
PE and I'm apparently not putting seat
you're just forgetting about the seat
because it isn't a practice that you
have cultivated yeah I've left it up huh
so now I'm I'm trying to you know I'm
having to make lots of changes you know
in my life right now they're all related
to the toilet you came to a fork in the
road you know and and you you you're
giving up you've placed a higher value
on not getting on the
phone than getting a little prosol in
the in the room or avoiding that really
I am placing the highest value and I I
don't want to camp out here but yeah
like just my your butthole Health my
butthole Health you got to think about
it it's important because you only got
one I just I mean most people I just
can't I just can't stay in that position
any longer than I need too it's not good
for me I'll leave it at
that um so so what that means is that
I've been trying my best to keep this
one
resolution and I'm not you know I'm I
don't know if I'm batting a
thousand or I might be batting about 300
which is good right you know I still
whip out my phone occasionally 30% of
the
time I'm not whipping out my phone on
the on the toilet it might be 50/50
maybe it's 60 maybe I'm doing okay I
every time that I sit on the toilet I am
thinking about the decision I made and
it's a more active decision if I'm
overriding it so I feel good about that
and I think that my body's going to
thank
me and and and so yeah and it's also
good to not be on the on the phone but
my wife's not thinking me yet cuz I got
to learn to push that seat back
down I thought I mean you've got a very
fancy toilet I thought it did it
automatically it start that part started
messing up within the first two months
when you walk I have the fanciest toilet
when you walk up to it it it had a lid
like the lid lid you you need to that
open to do anything yeah that would open
on its own and then that stopped working
you know that's interesting because I
have a semi fancy toilet mhm and that's
the first thing that went on that too
yep and so I turned that off so now my
toilet is not watching me constantly and
Reporting it to I don't know Google the
TBI the toilet Bureau of Investigation
yeah um well you're doing better than me
so I'm I'm trying I'm giving it my best
you're doing better than me because
you're trying you're not even trying to
keep your phone from your bedside table
you haven't even tried well let me
remind you unless I'm wrong uh I thought
that my resolution encompassed your
resolution and then extended it because
I thought I also said I didn't want to
poop with a phone yeah you did um I
pooped with the phone this morning I
mean I've already done
it and but actually sounds like you've
I'm not let me I'm not pooping with a
phone I'm not actually using the phone
as part of the pooping process I don't
even know what that would mean I'm
pooping while phoning I know it or
phoning while I know what you're
saying and it is a problem you didn't
even didn't even cross your mind um did
my life flash before your face I got to
say that I think I suffered
from a common
predicament in my life and probably your
life as well which is forgetting
something that we talked about oh you
totally yeah cuz you know you know the
blood blame the blood Blain barrier
something David bla came up with the
blood brain barrier yeah we have like
the camera life barrier and sometimes
you came up with a what you're saying is
you came up with the resolution just for
entertainment purposes well you start I
if I recall correctly you had a
resolution and I was bloming on to your
resolution yeah you were right and
because my resolution was on camera on
camera my resolution was made on camera
it did not pass the camera life barrier
all right that's fair that's fair I I I
totally understand I was in I was in a
mode now have you ever pooped on camera
with your phone in your hand
um no you had to think about it though
well I mean I wouldn't put it past us if
we have peed on camera we have plucked
our pubes on camera we hav filmed
anything except I don't think you could
I don't think we would poop on camera no
we to do we would we have farted on
camera by accident I almost
and then on purpose yeah God right uh
Jamie Jamie told us last conversation we
had with Jamie was like T Tik Tok
doesn't know what to do with like yeah
like bathroom talk yeah we we talk about
it too much and and I agree you know not
that this podcast is reduced to
something working on Tik Tok because we'
never think about that it hasn't but um
it does and uh here we are stepping
right in it yeah I don't know why we do
it but it's our resolution do
immature imature we're just being
ourselves and ourselves are immature no
we're just being human but you have
succeeded within the realm of being on
mic or camera you have not taken out
your phone while on the toilet so you
are you're doing it do you want to bring
this resolution into your non well the
thing that I was actually more
interested life the thing I was more
interested in was the bedside part of
this yeah that's where we and I will say
I have thought about this oh I have
thought about it
um
because I was like okay well what am I
going to do about an alarm I got to get
an alarm
clock I actually bought an alarm clock
for
Shephard because Shepherd everybody in
our house has a like a Google
home in the
room and so we can just be completely
tapped in at all times it's very very
healthy um
and that's how Shephard sets his alarm
mhm he's a 15-year-old though and
apparently it takes more than what
Google has to offer to wake up a
15-year-old I do not believe that there
is a an alarm volume all you have to do
is say stop I hear Lando saying that cuz
he does the same thing he's supposed to
get up at 700 and I hear him in there I
hear the alarm go off all he got to do
is say stop do you eventually have to go
get him up you don't this morning I did
yes oh good you don't have to move an
inch feel a little more you don't have
to your mouth is already open because
you're sleeping and I can tell he
doesn't even move his mouth he's like
stop and Google understands that do you
have to say Hey Google stop or just stop
all he says is stop because I think it's
when it's going it knows yeah when it's
going it knows it's way too easy yeah
yeah it's way too easy so and Shephard
you know we built a loft in his room so
his bed is
upstairs basically yep yep up a ladder
yep and I'm actually kind of
jealous you want to you want to sleep up
a ladder I I've always wanted to sleep
up a
ladder okay well put a bnk bed in your
bedroom Jesse's not into it oh really
yeah it's like she's my inter my
interior designer wife is not into the
idea she's giving a tour to her friends
that are curious what she did with the
bed bunk bed my husband insisted upon a
bunk
bed I mean that's a good design
challenge you each sleep in a bunk no we
both sleep on the top
bunk that's a loft right the bunk bed is
funnier I I I present to Jesse the
design challenge this is bloggable this
would this would go big on this on the
inner
sphere on the internet they almost
caught it that um back in 2020 14 never
mind go ahead um you bought an alarm for
Shephard so that he could get out out he
would have to climb down out in order to
deactivate it and I searched super loud
alarm oh God and you
did I just laughed and like I don't know
what's coming out my nose pass me those
tissues give me some tissues please pass
me the whole box oh God I can't I'm
drooling super loud alarm I can't even
imagine
it
um I haven't tested it yet it actually
arrived last night did you tell did you
tell him that you were doing this oh I I
I had Amazon open as I told him I am
currently buying you a super loud
alarm and it's going to be downstairs in
your two-story
room and you're going to have to get
your ass up to cut it off and basically
the whole house is going to be here in
it until you cut it off yeah so we'll
see I'll give you an update on that
later because it's not in yet I all I
know is you cannot say stop and get it
to stop
stop but we got him you we actually
talked about this on GMM years ago there
an alarm clock that would be on your
dresser or whatever and then when it
went off it would jump off of the the
dresser and roll around the room we got
him that and he hit it or
something CU we don't know where it's at
like I think he was like you're not
going to do this to me well he buried it
in the backyard I don't know where it is
probably going to kill this one too well
I'm not going to let that happen because
this is this is the battle that I'm
having right now is the I do not believe
that you should require my intervention
or Jesse's intervention to get up
because at some point you're not going
to have that in
life well but as i' so I've been
thinking about alarm clocks and you have
your own problems and uh boy uh once you
get into the world of alarm clocks
there's the one that looks like a half
Sun that a lot of people are into that
gets advertised to me on the ious
platforms yeah and it looks beautiful I
can't tell if it's 2et wide or you know
I haven't seen it in in my I haven't
done the thing where you put it in your
space using your phone I don't know how
big it is but it seems to be pleasant it
seems like it also doubles as a noise
machine like a noise machine this is the
trend um but I'm still trying to figure
out what that means about my phone and I
I did see some of your comments I will
say but you know what we got voicemails
from people that we're going to listen
to uh feedback on my predicament
okay hey Rett and Link I think I have a
very obvious answer to Rhett's issue
with the phone in the bedroom I think
the key is a pager system right you just
got to get a pager and then your loved
ones or your colleagues can send you a
page if something urgent comes up but
that way you don't have like social
media access or anything like that I
also strongly recommend a wake up light
you can find them on Amazon but they're
lights that slowly rise over a certain
amount of time so it feels like you're
waking up to the Sun and there's
different audios that you can choose so
you don't have to go with like a harsh
alarm sound I would love to see Rhett
walking around the pager on his hip so I
hope it worked out thanks bye what pager
I I didn't like I would love to see
Rhett walk around with a patreon is that
made me feel weird but I that's my
favorite part let's let's can we go
ahead and get the uh the light thing out
of the way because Jenna is giv like an
emphatic nod I I think it's the light
that I just described yes that was the
light yeah that's one of them oh I have
new mics yeah I know we' got new mics
reach over and grabbed an arm I was like
where she oh it's
it's look at this we don't even same
Mike same Mike's different uh we we've
got yeah we've got
little very official mhm so do you have
one of these I I don't because I I uh
use what I already have and since I have
a a Google home I have automatic um I
have it automatically set up that my
lights certain lights come on when the
Sun rises okay in my room in your room I
I could in my room cuz like I don't have
like uh where where my room is like the
light it's just kind of like it it's not
super bright the sun doesn't shine in it
okay so you live in a cave yes I do man
first of all you know I was into the I I
I went really hard into the whole Google
home and all the lights and everything
when we installed them and I've got I
have routines that are set up but I
haven't added
anything and I haven't played around
like I've got lights
on in each lamp on the sides of the bed
that can be any color that a human can
see Sunrise there you go
so I think Jesse might be into that
uh but the the lights that they're
talking about in the voicemail are it
like slowly simulates the sunrising like
it's much more gradual it's a gradual
have you not seen the one that looks
like the sun uh-uh that's cool it's
really pretty yeah I I would love one of
those but I I already have stuff that
can kind of do the same thing so it it
seemed like a waste of money to to get
that when I could just do other things
the one I see all the time is the hatch
restore not a sponsor I don't know if
it's any good I just see people talking
about it
but um what does it connect to Google
home it connects to your phone see
because if you go to the top it's like
oh you got an app and you're and you're
you're doing all this stuff it's only
just $130 which is a lot to pay for an
alarm but
mhm I'm over here for bless you bless D
are you okay I was waiting I thought you
were going to do a third one I like to
do it at the end instead of like for
each uh anyway I'm not I haven't I just
haven't fixed it yet and
pager I love that IDE that's hilarious
you can still buy a pager but I only
need a pager at night it's a night pager
I don't need a pager all the time you
would keep it by your bed it would just
be a a a bedside pager I would wear a
belt bed and it would be on the Belt
yeah she would she would never see you
wearing a pager it would be a bedside
pager I think I well I think I can kill
two birds with one stone because you
remember that belt that I bought that
had plastic balls on each side and the
stomach to so you had to sleep on your
back
yeah uh I don't know what I did with it
it
broke Shephard buried it with that I
need to get I need to get the back
sleeping belt back and I need to put a
pager on put a pager on it you're like
you what I'm going to do I'm going to
get a regular belt and I just put a
pager on my belly yes and that way and I
gotta get three pagers yep two yep there
you go so I give my mom three different
numbers that she can call it gives her a
better chance of getting in touch with
me Mom these are my three new pager
numbers also it keeps me from rolling
over don't worry I'm not going to
explain it well get can I have a pager
can Jesse have a pager and can your mom
have a pager yeah which hip you want
left or right left link left yeah Mom
middle Jesse on the right I don't have a
way to make that work okay so that's my
three pager system and you can't roll
over on those pagers look at that I got
to get big pagers
though pagers are are probably really
tiny now so I need a old pager a big
brick ass
pager uh cuz you're not sleeping on your
back man you keep you keep adding things
you need to do I here's the thing I
tried the back sleeping thing that belt
broke and then I was my back got better
I was doing it for my back okay my back
ended up getting better and so I was
like maybe I don't need to do that okay
but we somebody else gave another
suggestion let's listen to
that hey R link this is christe uh I was
just listening to the podcast where
Rhett is talking about not wanting to
keep his cell phone in his bedroom
anymore at night or in the morning
um but still needing there to be a way
someone could contact him in case of an
emergency and you're like asking what
device that could be and I totally get
that and I think the device that you
need to get is a
landline and only us old people will
know what a landline is anymore or will
have ever used one and jenzy probably
has no clue what I'm talking about but
uh yeah I think you need to get a
landline so that someone could still
call you and you might be looked at as a
bit of an old guy but you know what
you Embrace that because you are old and
I'm old and there you go I love the fact
that love you she thinks Jess so much
younger than you that she doesn't know
what a landline is like the age
difference would have to be like she was
your daughter I'm two years three two
years older I thought she said genen Z
but I could be wrong
oh okay all right all right that that
makes more sense I do call Jesse jenzy
jzy jenzy Jesse Yeah it's very
I'm going start calling Jesse jenzy Yeah
okay that makes more sense you know
literally up
until three months ago I had a landline
wow you did yeah where was it um so when
we the phone itself was in locks room
because that's where the internet comes
into the house yeah and so that's where
the one little phone jack was and when
we signed up for cable and internet
eight years ago they still gave you a
line we got a landline and so I was like
well this is pretty cool having a
landline is a good you know it's a good
backup it's a it's a way to get in touch
never gave the landline out to anyone
somebody had it though oh really you
know it was a number that it was a
recycled number
so three times a year we would get a
phone call that we would not
answer that felt weird didn't it and uh
why is Lock's room ringy and I had this
idea
that if I can't get in touch with you
guys when we're out and we need to get
in touch with you I've got this landline
number but it was a very dad thing that
did not go beyond the dad family barrier
yeah this doesn't work this doesn't work
because you would have to give that
number to only the You' give it to a set
number of people who would not keep it
and I would be like if you need to get
in touch with me at between these hours
you call this number it it's putting the
onus on other people which is also the
problem with the pager it's like what I
want is a a device in my house I've
already told you where if you call my
number at
night it still wakes me up but my phone
is not in the bedroom how's that what do
I do do I get what do I do just put the
Dune not I've already told you what to
do put the put your do not disturb on
that the functionality exists for people
to break through if they call three
times or whatever if they're on a
certain list the phone is still there
put it on the other side of the room the
phone is still present in the room but
it's not in by by your bed but the Wi-Fi
is giving me cancer
but that that's all you need to do man
we've sat here and we've talked about
this so much and we're back at the exact
same place I'm so embarrassed for our
for us yeah we don't know we don't make
progress it's frustrating to watch right
but like we're not even three weeks into
the new year and it's even less than
that when we're actually recording this
but I feel like I'm doing okay but
you're doing okay I've been I've been uh
I've been reading you're doing okay
because you haven't started now you can
start I haven't been on my phone in the
bed very much I'll say that I've been
put your phone in the charger at at over
there across on Jesse
side sure but and listen you're doing
this to
Shepherd yeah you need to do this to
yourself man
I just got to get the alarm cl you know
what one day Shepherd's not going to be
there to have nothing to do with this
problem like he currently doesn't yeah
what am I you're going to have I'm going
to be sleeping in this bunk bed you're
going to have to yeah right you're going
to be I'll be sneaking out every night
after me and Jesse go to bed and I'll be
in the bunk bed when we we wake up it's
just funner up here I feel so
high uh yeah okay I'll figure it out
don't worry about me I just figured it
out for you um I did all the work uh we
have another voicemail we have another
voicemail hey this is Adler from 10
years in the future I just listened to
the I'm capsule episode from 2014 and I
found in my calendar to listen to this
old ear biscuit so I did and I'd say the
funniest thing I found listening to it
10 years later is hearing Rett say that
he didn't take people on a Google meet
or a a zoom link type of meeting he
didn't take them seriously because they
were on a screen and uh now that's
that's all we do
so pretty funny yeah I still don't take
them
seriously even yourself yeah so uh many
of you reached out at the beginning of
the year letting us know I don't know
I've got this reminder on my phone
telling me to listen to this old ear
biscuit I love the fact that this
happened and they didn't know why right
figure it out because when we told you
to make a reminder it wasn't we didn't
it didn't come with an explanation but
many of you did figure out it was asking
you to listen to an episode from 10
years ago in which we tried to uh create
a moment in time a time capsule of the
way things were and then there were some
predictions that we made about the way
things would be in 2024 um before we get
into those I just want to take a second
to
acknowledge something pretty awesome we
put the first Good Mythical
evening uh which is you know back from
2021 when you know the
R-rated completely unhinged we didn't
know what to predict cuz it was the
first time we had ever done
it um and it it was wild and if you
weren't there for it you didn't get to
see it if you didn't rent it for the
next few days well now we put it on the
mythical Society where it's going to
live permanently for streaming if you
are a second or third degree member of
the mythical Society you can watch the
first Good Mythical evening at your
leisure whenever you want to um and if
you're third degree you can also watch
the after show so I'm not going to
rewatch it because uh just for your own
sake just for my own sake it was a it
was a it was a bit extra
you know the mythical Society my
inebriation was a bit extra the mythical
Society continues to
be uh I don't know man I I'm just very
excited about what we've got going on
over there I'm gonna I'm going to take a
moment to just add on to what you just
said because you know we're celebrating
um very soon next month celebrating the
fifth anniversary of the mythical
society and uh you know we start a lot
of things as you know we start a lot of
things we try a lot of things we don't
necessarily stick with everything
because some things don't work and uh
I'm very proud of the fact that our team
has done such a good job with the
mythical Society in making it better and
better yeah and making it what I think
is based on everything that I can see
the best paid fan club on the internet
can I just say that in terms of the
amount of things the the amount yeah you
got to be if if you're a fan of
something and then this is the thing
that's offered I just think with the
number of things that keep getting added
over there and the the number of things
that people can experience the the
cumulative value yeah I just inre I
think the team does an incredible job
with that and uh the membership
continues to grow over there and it is
like the most mythical experience that
you can have like that was the whole
point of it was to create something that
where does the the most mythicality live
it
lives at the mythical Society exclusive
and worth paying for yeah you know so
that's what we've
done earbiscuits is supported by chime
it's a new year you might have some new
goals that you are setting for yourself
you might want to get yourself a car
maybe you want to get yourself a a new
place to live you've got things that
you're trying to pay for save for ETC
and you know what one of the the key
ingredients in that is having a good
credit score having some credit built up
no matter how you're starting off the
year when you use the secured chime
credit Builder Visa credit card you can
build your credit scores with ontime
payments for everyday purchases there
are no annual fees interest or credit
check to apply and by the way you get a
checking account too with chime you can
get paid up to 2 days early with a
qualifying direct deposit and when you
set up that direct deposit you can sign
up for spot me and chime will spot you
up to your limit when you make a credit
card purchase or cash withdrawal that
exceeds your balance not to mention
access to 60,000 plus fee free ATMs
that's more than the top three National
Banks combined start building your
credit open a chime checking account
with at least a $200 qualifying direct
deposit to get started get started at
chime.com
that's chime.com the chime credit
Builder Visa credit card is issued by
the bank Court Bank NA or stride Bank NA
members FDIC out of network ATM
withdrawal and overthe counter Advance
fees May apply call 8442446363
3 for details late payment May
negatively impact your credit score
results May Vary Early Access to direct
deposit funds depends on payers spot me
eligibility requirements and overdraft
limits
apply okay so let's get back to these
things we should start by saying uh
Aloha because that's what we said would
be the greeting in
2024 and we're right we're right I think
it can still happen I hear it everywhere
I mean um you know if you travel to
certain places it's uh it's a common
saying and it's catching
on um right I mean what yeah I will know
we're at the beginning of the year you
know maybe we should wait till the end
it could be the year of Aloha it could
be let's let's actually make that
happen I don't know if we can make that
happen no you know what I'm saying oh
yeah culturally yeah yeah we shouldn't
be the ones to make it if it's going to
happen we can be along for the ride but
I don't think we could try to make it
happen that's a good point um I agree
with
that we talked of that idea we talk that
a good the beauty of it is it's hello
that's what we said that's that's that's
what we were thinking that everyone
would understand now we talked about the
fashion at the time we called ourselves
hipsters uh in a non-derogatory way
maybe it should have been derogatory we
were wearing skinny jeans at the
time um glad that's over and there was a
discussion not a prediction as much of a
as a discussion about where we were
going to go from here could they get
tighter for me I was definitely already
like I really hope they do not get any
tighter they couldn't like there were
tighter jeans than I ended up wearing
you were a little bit tighter than me
but then there were jeans that were
tighter than the jeans that you were
wearing jeans that look like leggings
you know what I'm saying that was a
thing that some people wore yeah what
were we thinking
man the same thing we're thinking now
it's all sub
man it's just like you think that things
look good when they it's not that they
look good they just look new and
different or whatever right cuz the
magazines have like really dramatic
Lighting on people wearing whatever it
is they think you we were conjecturing
and one of the possibilities was that
with the the trend would reverse and it
really has I mean Shephard wears the
pipe jeans you know basically je but we
didn't we didn't give a hard prediction
that like oh we're going to we're going
to be in these like ballooning
pants we so we can't take credit for
that yeah right you were more hopeful
that they would go in the other
direction felt forced into the skinny
jeans I feel like they went too far
though they're too big I'm saying for a
6 foot s man with my body shape there's
a there's a too skinny and too big big
guys don't look good on the extreme ends
of the fashion Spectrum it's just hard
for us and so I think like
a like a
Levis
501 Jean or whatever yeah whatever the
like middle Gene is is the gene that is
objectively the best looking Gene well
it's a dad Gene but but when you're a
dad you can't wear it it doesn't work
I've got a pair of 501s yeah well what
you got on is kind of dadish it does
work I guess um these are bigger you
know okay and the funny thing about
these is link it's not actually a Jee
isn't that interesting no what what do
you mean it's technically classified as
a
Chino that's interesting to me I don't
know what that means but it just I it's
just like a different cut but it's it
looks like jeans but it's not
denim it is denim well it's a different
type of denim that is a is a Chino I
don't understand it's just like it very
confused difference between a Chino and
a
jean that's what we need to know if
we're going to get to the next years
that's what we need to know like look
like see this thing like look it's like
more like it's more pantsy it's more
pancy yeah it says chinos are made from
Chino cloth which is similar to Denim
but denim is classically a heavier fiber
where Chino cloth is lighter weight you
see it's very th it's very
thin Chino okay but they're bigger I if
I had to choose between these and what
we had in 2014 definitely these because
these are much more comfortable I mean
the pandemic had like a huge accelerant
on on this
change but I would have thought that 10
years is plenty of time to be to balloon
pants this big I don't know what the
cycle is because it will start getting
small
again we thought that we talked about
ties because skinny ties are in of
course they're not in anymore but what
we thought was that in 2024
it would be all about the bolo tie the
skinniest of tie the skinniest of tie
where it becomes like a shoelace around
your neck uhuh and we were wrong about
that and we just have to we just have to
come out and
say we were wrong I hate bolos about
bolo ties and we
are sorry sorry I'm not sorry we're
sorry that we got anyone excit anyone
was hurt there's I know some I don't
apologize if no one was hurt somebody
started buying up bolo TI okay if you
went into debt because you boled up back
in 2014 I'm
sorry well in between over the past 10
years somebody was like investing in a
bolo business yeah oh yeah that's true
there's probably a bolo business out
there because of us because of us that
failed um I will say I think the thing
that really
derailed I we I don't even know what the
Thai fashion is now again because of the
pandemic when do you wear a tie now no
tie you wear a tie when you go to
something that is definitively formal
you don't wear TI people Don't Wear Ties
to work like no agents have you notice
this agents and and and lawyers
attorneys but but the one that changed
the most is Agents agents in 2014 if you
went into a talent agency H agents were
wearing suits and ties
hm you're right they NE you you go into
an agency now nobody's got a suit and no
one has a tie on no
one that's right man we got to we got to
get them back you go into you go into a
law firm now and they might have on a
dress shirt now we're not talking about
just for clarity we're not talking about
secret agents right we're talking about
entertainment agents we don't know
anything about we don't know any secret
agents well we maybe we do right we just
don't know if we do
exactly uh but I don't think they're
wearing ties because I don't see anybody
wearing ties so there maybe that's what
makes them secret ties got
derailed yeah and we don't care now we T
in the in the area of tech we were
talking about what we call the new Apple
eyew
watch which was not what it was called
ever except maybe like two years before
it came out when people were predicting
it but this is after it came out and it
was called the Apple watch was just
announced and we didn't know how to I
don't know which one of us said it but I
apologize for whoever did it was R yeah
it was it was you again man um talking
about the eyewatch I did I probably
didn't even know it existed you knew it
existed and called it the
eyewatch uh I might call it the eyewatch
now just kind of slipping up I apologize
if you bought uh if you invested in iew
watch.com back in 2014 thinking that it
was going to be the big thing and it's
build a business it was actually Apple
watch incidentally I don't know the
latest on this but uh apple apple
watches got shut down did you know about
this there was a government regulations
places there's like some the phones got
shut down in France but then the watch
got shut down the eyew watch because of
a lawsuit because of a a patent lawsuit
oh not because of radiation no
because the the latest version of the
latest couple of versions maybe of of
the watch of the eyewatch um they were
using some other technology and that and
they successfully sued I haven't checked
in on it I don't know what the latest is
I don't wear an Apple Watch anymore
because I'm trying to remove myself from
The
Matrix okay the US uh can temporar let's
so an apple can temporarily sell them
because the US appeals court win okay oh
yeah I knew Apple they would figure
something they got much money they got
they got a lot when you got that much
money can can anybody really stop
you I hope so
Holograms why did we talk so much about
Holograms they were we said they were
only projections for Tupac and Michael
Jackson but our prediction was that
video conferencing would be in hologram
form that has not happened I mean but we
were at least talking about video
conferencing mhm you know because that's
what you want that's what we thought we
wanted because you you disrespected
video conferencing so much that you were
like the only way that it will catch on
is is if they feel like they're sitting
in the room like the Jedi
Council yeah and hasn't happened the
technology is and and it won't too
complicated because not and there's no
demand for it because everybody's on
board with this thing that you dis you
didn't respect which is meeting via a
screen what I do think will happen not
that we're making predictions but now I
am the thing that is much more likely to
happen than an actual
hologram is an augmented reality version
of the person you're talking to on some
sort of device that you're looking
through like
meaning well you know how you like you
look at your phone it's flat it's a no
when you look at a augmented reality
through your phone like if you're
playing Pokemon go poke whatever it is
and it's like I I can put a little poke
thing on my yeah po or I can like
visualize this couch in my room using my
phone um I mean that's a thing that that
the eyeg glasses that Apple came out
with ey glasses um that are too
expensive and people are not buying but
it's just as much AR as
VR right I think what'll happen is
you'll just
have a way of interacting with somebody
in in AR I'm not saying that's going to
happen I'm saying it's not going to be
Holograms it would be ar if it was
anything in terms of a three-dimensional
interaction with
somebody because what Holograms is it's
like you got to have like a system right
that no one's gonna
have um but I still don't really take
people on video conferences uh seriously
like I let me just say
if I'm in a real meeting with people and
one person couldn't show up and they're
on a computer I take them a little less
seriously well and not you're not giving
them as much love even subconsciously
yeah it's like oh you're a computer
person everyone else is real person here
yeah you're yeah you know if it's going
to take a lot for us you're not as smart
in me thought you were all of us to shut
up and listen to
you I mean on the computer you don't
carry as much weight unless you're on a
really big
computer so we got to do something about
that because it's hybrid now so there is
a competition some people in the room
happens a lot here now so many meetings
are hybrid meetings a lot of people in
the room and oh yeah there yeah yep
there's the person on the screen talking
yeah we were talking about self-driving
cars um and how people didn't trust it
and it's like it's the same nothing's
changed this is this is one of the
remarkable things right
because I think I talked about the fact
that people would that we would have
moved forward in the conversation by now
right Jamie is that what I said yeah
there's no progress it doesn't
technology progress but like well you
got people like Elon
who if you it's you can go back and see
what he has said every single year and
he always talks about how it'll happen
next year it'll be fully automated it'll
be great whatever and it never happens
yeah um and as you know and as you have
shamed me into admitting I drive a Tesla
and
um I have done the fully automated
driving a number of times and at least
10 times I've thought that I'm going to
die like it it's it it makes so many
dumb decisions at crucial points where I
have to like grab it back from itself so
I just think that the I do think it'll
eventually happen but I am stunned at
how little progress has been made in 10
years and how the distrust that I would
have like looked down
upon you now act upon I now am part of
I'm like well I listen I think I do a
better job than this thing I I shouldn't
a machine should be better at it but
they're not
yet we predicted that presidents would
be digital we couldn't have meant that
but uh I I think maybe we meant that
like we talked about dead relatives
being digitized being uploaded to hard
drives well we didn't talk about AI I
mean we should have talked about AI we
didn't know anything about it we didn't
know anything about it and look at it
now it is the it is the main thing it is
I mean it is such a huge like Earth
shaking Watershed
development and it's happening so
quickly that I never want to talk about
it on a in on a recording that comes out
a week later because it's already
irrelevant old yeah that things are
moving that quickly you know but we have
to talk about the thing that we that I
showed you the other
night because when you talk about the
dead relative yeah I mean because that
is happening we were right about this
one in a sense or we can now see that
it's about to happen so I was and
again when we talk about these things
like you said
a couple of weeks will pass before this
comes out so I don't know what will
happen and this could have been revealed
to be totally fake or whatever but
uh I stumbled upon a tick tock from the
dudy podcast which is Will Sasso who's a
comedian from Mad TV Great impressionist
and then some other guy sorry I'm
calling other guy I don't know I don't
know anything about these guys I don't
know nothing about the podcast other
than I keep seeing clips of them
reacting to AI things audio video and
they're just laughing about it and I
don't know who's making it but you can
kind of tell it's AI generated images
and then AI generated uh voice models of
famous people saying stuff that seems
like it was written by Ai and it's
hilarious me because
will at least of the two I don't know I
don't know the sorry I'm calling the
other guy too is um an impressionist
right an excellent one yeah so like his
Jesse The Body Ventura is oh yeah uh
Immaculate so and that's important the
uh but the he's reacting to the
impersonations that AI can do of right
and I don't know who's making it and I
don't know what role I don't understand
any of the elements of it of it all I
know is that they
released a
onehour George Carlin special of George
Carlin commenting on modern-day events
yeah and it was called I'm glad I'm not
dead and it was a special and at the top
of it I'm glad I am dead I'm sorry I'm
glad I'm I am dead the now first of all
you just listen to it I'd make a couple
of observations about it it is
legitimately funny legitimately
insightful very hard to uh decipher or
pick up on the fact that it's AI there's
a couple of places where it's like okay
that maybe there was some uncanny valley
thing about the way that was put that
feels a little bit like maybe it was
generated uhuh but if you didn't know
that that you were supposed to be
listening for that you would be like
this is George Carlin doing he's still
alive and he's doing a comedy routine
about 2024 right now in the state of the
world giving the same types of insights
that he would typically give the preface
of this one hour
special from another AI that I guess is
dudy I don't know again I don't know
much about this is claiming that the
thing is entirely generated by AI
because when I sent it to you you were
like I think probably what happened is
this is a voice model and the guy's like
doing an impersonation of it and then
it's like modeled using AI but they
wrote the jokes like people wrote the
jokes mhm
ostensibly they didn't write the jokes
and that this was AI figuring it out but
it's hard to believe that AI would be
this good right now at comedy but like
we talked about when we were talking
about the other
day it's going to be that good at comedy
it's only matter of time and it's and
there's I mean you can take the body of
work of George Carlin because it exists
in media and you can give it to AI now
you so if you have a dead relative who
has a body of media then you can do that
if you don't you can't so like for
us we can to we can totally be think
about how much preserved [__] we've said
on the internet oh my gosh we like like
for for for our kids grandkids great
grandkids we will like that is the
prediction is that we will be a part of
their lives you will be a without doubt
you will be able to unless they don't
want us to be and then they just they
just turn us off but here's the thing
you and I yes we put all we put
ourselves out there and we there's
enough information by far enough
information to we're in like to create
create an AI that to create an AI that
then is perfectly situation uh set up to
react in a situation exactly how we
would react like if I was talking to
link based on everything that he's done
this thing is going to react it's going
to say the same things it's going to
make the same observations it's going to
have the same Cadence and it's going to
be indecipherable from you if you were
still alive you that's easy for us but
if you just you know how every time you
uh you get an app on your phone and it
asks you to get permission to access
your your your
photos yeah well every person has a
whole bunch of selfies and videos of
themselves from their entire lives yes
if you give the AI permission to get
intoh the digital record that you've
already created of yourself tot it can
do the same thing for you it can do the
same thing for anyone you don't have to
be an Entertainer yeah I mean we we are
in the like end times the top like you
and with the amount
of
impromptu content that we've put out
into the world we are in like the top
percentile of people like with the
amount of
quality data to give AI
like
my I guess my
kids they don't they still don't take a
lot of video of themselves they're not
making podcasts
you know so I I don't think it's a
robust data set at this point because
everybody's not a content creator so if
yeah so but it's the more data the
better the model obvious so it's like
just a handful of
like Christmas present opening videos or
like I'm just trying to think what my
kids actually film of themselves it's
actually not that much but you could
also if I mean this technology is gonna
be like okay do you give do you give
this app permission to listen to monitor
you for the next month well yeah there
you go all you got to do is do that it's
it's going to be so easy to give it the
information that it needs in order to
create the model but then them but but
again that's just a voice model it's not
like physical
mannerisms that's why
we
like we're in that percentile because
like it can observe so much about us
like it's not scripted it's it's there's
the physicality of it like you know it's
the the George Carlin thing did not have
any video that's kind of a point I'm
making it didn't have video of Carlin
but it had video it had but it could
have of vide it looked like Dolly uh
generated images and some video where
like the mouth would move but it wasn't
it was um complimentary visuals that you
had something to look at for the hour
but they could they totally could do it
with him like put him on a stage and
like have the have his eyebrows behave
in the way that they do when he delivers
his punch lines it's all just a matter
of time right but I'm I'm just analyzing
when does that trickle down to any
relative and I don't think I just don't
think it's a direct line but how do we
go through that if one of us dies I
here's the prediction I'm going to make
the other one's going to be replaced
with AI and we're going to keep going in
some way like like we that is I mean it
will happen right if if we don't die at
the same time and the other person is
capable enough to still make content the
other guy will be
AI man I mean and and it will
be
indistinguishable to the viewer through
the screen now in the room in real life
will it be a hologram what will it
be I don't know it's like will will will
you talk to dead me differently you know
in the way that you think that you talk
to people in the zoom call versus in the
room
differently you you'll forget the thing
I think about is I mean that's a that
that scenario is like yeah it's kind of
mind-blowing to think that that you hang
out with me when we're not doing the
podcast and you can ask this question
about any person because you think about
your parents right so
so our parents are older right my
parents are older than yours my parents
are almost 80 years old yeah M are and
so I think about do I want to think
about however many years they have left
on this planet in this form to interact
with them okay um and it's just like
that's
it that's all it needs to be and that's
what we've always experienced as humans
there's no need to have them beyond
having pictures of them and maybe some
video of them do I really need because
it's a completely different level of
interaction to be like I'm going to have
an AI version and we we talked about
this exact same thing because this was a
concept like 10 years ago at that
website where you could interact with
somebody but because the technology has
gotten so much better now it's like
right oh I actually think there might be
a way that I could interact with
somebody and I wouldn't be able to
really tell a a distinct difference and
there's a whole movie about this
um several movies about this but there's
one oh that we watched at
Sundance uh yes that Mom the mom was had
a
disease she had dementia and so dementia
they like made the AI version of her or
something I don't know and then the the
reveal was that you were experiencing
the simulated the robotic mom the whole
time the whole time um man I don't know
it's all I mean I saw some of the I read
some of the comments because the this
video we where I where I ranted and my
fears about Ai and it's just funny to
see the reaction there's lots of people
who are like this is a total
overreaction there's some people like I
can't listen to this when he starts
talking like this I can't listen or
whatever I get it I get it like I told
you at the beginning it's like I don't
like to talk about it it's just I have
to like I just had to get it out now
some people are like yes this is super
scary to me I don't I honestly don't
know what to think about it because when
you like the scenario that you
just envisioned of the realistic option
within we're probably talking months
rather than years of of us having the
ability to replace one of us with an an
AI version W without lifting a finger
but like I don't even know how to
process I I even think about the fact
that like so many of our we've recounted
so many of
our life experiences we've told so many
stories from from so much information is
there to like e even give like the
proper backstory so that the AI can pull
from that I think that what's going to
happen is
that you know we we talk about your
brain being uploaded but the next thing
you know to a hard drive or to a cloud
or whatever so that when you're when
you're dying or if you're if you're you
know if you're deg denigrating if you're
if you're going
downhill and you want to start saving
your brain or whatever the way that it
will happen first is like all right uh
Rhett you're uh sorry to hear about your
diagnosis well it's not you it's
somebody let's just say it's um thank
you let's say it's your brother how
about just somebody we don't know Mr X
I'm trying to make it personal okay and
I don't have a you
know anyway you have a half brother I
have a half brother talk about him why
you know I I don't know I'm not bringing
my half brother into this what you
bringing my whole brother into it yeah
because I mean okay whatever there's
somebody that we don't know but that we
care about deep Mr X all right and
um so all right we're sending you the
package we're sending you the box you're
going to be monitored you're going to
get you know the way that it create the
way that you create voice voice models
now is all right just say this script
and now the AI has heard everything from
your voice to then make you say anything
so let's fill out the rest of the data
set we're going to watch you do all
these things you're just going to stand
in the box and you're going to you're
going to do this you're going to squat
you're going to turn it's like setting
up you're going to smile face ID on a
iPhone right and you're going to you're
going to tell your stories you're going
to dump as much information as you can
answer these 72 questions and it gives
us all the information we need to create
a profile of you right and the more
questions you answer and the more
stories you tell about your past and the
more the the more that like react to
this statement react to this piece of
video all all you know you get a profile
of their instincts and everything you
know everything that we have already
given to AI can be created with it
anybody can give it with just like a
little box that can be sent that's what
I'm saying
where it's probably just go to this
website use this
webcam more the more days you do it the
more you're giving yourself to you're
making yourself Immortal yeah you're
talking about it in the context of
immortality or like being able to have
this record of yourself after you gone
right which is very legitimate I think
the thing that will happen maybe even
sooner than that for us is someone is
Gonna Come to Us because somebody's
already doing this they're already
thinking about this and they're going to
be
like uh we have a service where you guys
can have a virtual version of yourselves
you can put it on your mythical Society
where there's a chat there's a video
room that you can go into and anybody
who logs in can interact with you guys
yeah and it will be it will seem almost
as good as a real interaction and it is
an it can be infinitely scaled because
it's just a
model
uh and they're going to be like do you
want to do
that and then we're going to be faced
with well how do you make this decision
how do you make a decision as to whether
or not you would let yourself have this
Avatar of a perfect Avatar or close to
perfect Avatar of yourself that somebody
can interact with how do you make a
decision as to whether or not you would
do that because it would be pretty
[__] awesome in one sense for people
to be able to do that right but then in
another cency would be like well it's
not real and it does it Del I don't I'm
not even beginning to evaluate it I'm
just saying can you toggle on or off
like the romance switch because I don't
want I don't want to be married to a
bunch of people I don't want to be in
like some sort of romantic partnership
well I think that would be a feature
that no this is not a romance thing
you're
togging speaking of that for a prize
speaking of that and if honestly if the
only thing I was I cared about in the
world was making money the thing that I
would be working on right now and again
I'm sure people are working on
it when you when you everybody dates
online everybody uses dating apps to to
meet people or most people do and you go
on to someone's profile and what is
their profile their profile is a series
of pictures of them maybe a video or two
and some information that they have
decided to curate about themselves for
you to make a decision as to whether or
not you were you will swipe left or
right yeah yeah yeah there what should
be happening right now and what will
happen this
year or next is one of these dating
sites will be the first to un to roll
out the Avatar that you interact with in
order to make your decision as to
whether or not you want to date this
person M yep because why am I yes why am
I going to spend the time on the profile
if I could just have the interaction
with the Avatar and people are just
going to start making a decision like do
I want my Avatar to be how
representative of it do I want it to be
is is it going to be more fun to be with
my avatar because I held some stuff back
or whatever like these are lot there's a
lot of ethical questions to ask about
this should you even do that do you want
to opt into this thing but if it can
make you if it enhan first of all if
somebody can make money off of it it
will happen right that's the first thing
if somebody's willing to pay for it
because they think that it's valuable
like well I want to date more people
yeah I i' like I'd like this to be a
more efficient process if it makes it a
more efficient process there's value in
it people will pay for it so what will
happen is then be like okay why don't
I'm going to
date her Avatar I'mma talk to her Avatar
a few times to see if I hit it off with
the Avatar and before I decide to waste
her time and mine to like actually date
her and then I'm like you know what I'm
just going to let my avatar date her
Avatar and then just just spit out of
I'll check in on them and see how much
fun they're having this is probably a
Black Mirror episode I haven't seen all
of them but I'm sure it is and then and
then it's not going to be just for
dating it's going to be well the app's
going to tell you how your avatar is
interacted and whether or not you're a
match and then in the meantime you're
dating someone else in the real world
and you're deciding like am I going to
switch over to date the real person
associated with this Avatar that my
avatar is dating and is there a window
of time that you have to there'll be
apps where it's like well you have to
agree if your avatars are dating you
can't you can't date anybody in the room
real world you got to like have a window
of time when like you're open to it but
because it's all just based on computer
power literally all you have to do is if
you enter yourself into this cohort of
people who are all there they would all
date each other the computer runs a
simulation of everyone dating everyone
and then immediately spits out what your
best matches are yeah but then your best
match is somebody else's best match is
somebody else's best match and nobody
matches up and that's what we learn i'
be no but but then people have to make a
decision like they're because that's not
how relationships work you have your
avatar is an A+ match with the following
people and then you then people are like
well does my avat do I agree with my
avatar do I agree with what this
computer decided I should think about
this person all this shit's going to
happen or it could happen and we just
decide that we don't want it to happen
that's another thing that I see anytime
people talk about this stuff again I
hate talking about it but I canot talk
about it because
this it's we've never lived in a time
where it's so accessible the the science
fiction nature of it and how quickly it
can advance and you can just like
imagine oh well actually it would do
this and actually would do this is
actually something that is happening and
will happen very soon and that's why
it's just sort of mind I'll put it this
way I think that my
mom will understand AI in
three
years and I'm not saying something bad
about my mom it's just like she there's
no it's going to penetrate Society to
the point that like your parents your
grandparents are going to just use it
they're just going to use it and
understand it because it's going to be
so much easier than like when you know
when the when gooey was invented you
know oh this when when Microsoft Windows
came out and then all of a sudden now so
many more people can use computers you
know it's so much more accessible than
that the way that it's going to work the
way that my mom can use her phone and
has adapted to that is because it's
gotten so easy like yeah my mom is
listening to this conversation the
interface two year two two years ago my
mom did could not listen to ear
biscuits like as much as I tried it just
didn't work and now here she is
listening to it hi Mom and would you
want your mom to if you didn't have time
again it seems cold to even ask this
question if you didn't have time to talk
to your mom but there was an avatar and
your mom and you found out that your mom
like when you were home that's what
listen that's what my mom already does
when I go home she's like she's been
hanging out with you anyway I feel so
close to you cuz I see you every day cuz
there's something exactly it's already
happening now that other guy's always
there yeah I don't have to be there
right you know what I'm saying if if
it's your the Avatar and if it's not
something that it works emotionally if
it's not something for everybody but
it's something just for
you you can hang out with your son every
single every single day you can have you
can have tea with your son yeah and I
can hang out with my mom and she's dead
she's you're saying when I mean that
don't don't manifest that man I'm not I
don't believe in manifestation I don't
think I don't either I was just saying
yeah one day when she's dead if I send
her the package I got to get I got to
get all her
information so she can she can be
chilling in the living room there's so
much money in this is the one thing that
I'm thinking like when somebody figures
it out and they're like you can send in
a way that you can like get ancestor.com
you can get 23 in their pants right now
you get 23 in me is ancestry by the way
right but ancestor is probably so you
you give you give the gift of 23 in me
to family members right and sometimes
you regret that when you find out it's
not your
dad but this is the this is GNA in the
next 10 years right it's first of all if
we don't destroy ourselves yes you will
be able to buy this package that you can
send to your relative and then they can
do this thing or whatever and then it's
just like they will be here with you
forever and
because people want the comfort of the
interaction with the Dead relative more
than they're willing to explore the
ethical
complications they're going to buy it
yeah it's irresist so much money in it
it's going to be irresistible now so
we've sat here and we so we've talked
about go ahead and set your reminder for
10 years from now
2034 hey Siri remind me to listen to
earbiscuits in
January
2024 okay my phone is now trying to
respond my computer didn't I think
there's another way to say
this what what day does this come out uh
January 22nd okay hey
Siri remind me in January 234 to listen
to the earbiscuits episode from January
22nd
okay I added that for January
134 okay okay well I added you added it
to mine
too it thinks you're me you know
everyone listening is going to yeah
there we go so we we'll see you in
another 10 years y'all and we we I mean
we didn't even mean to do this but we
started basically we're making the
prediction that we're making is that
it's just about AI some that's the point
these AI things are just going to be
nothing else matters life will be
defined by
it life will be defined by it or we will
just collectively I'm not saying it's we
do have willpower we have the ability to
be like we don't want life to be defined
by it we don't have that much will power
you have less power than you realize
because money is involved and the people
want people want to make money man but
there's good people with
money yeah but people are most people
are just subjects of whatever system
they're in yeah man you know what I'm
saying saying it's just like you just
live according to the system that you're
born into you're a
capitalist and you work for money and
you spend it because that's the system
that dominates the way that the world
works it's a weird feeling like I have
such a weird feeling right now about the
next 10 years it I wonder what I felt
like at the end of the last episode like
10 years ago it's like it's not that cuz
now I'm like I didn't have a sense of I
had no existential dread in 2014
I was just like there's some cool [__]
that's going to happen I mean now it's
now I post pandemic I wake up in
existential dread and we're we're
pre pre
AI Singularity or whatever so it's like
it's it is a different world you know
and I I I'm feeling that right now that
like I feel totally different about 10
years from now
versus what I felt like 10 years 10
years from now will be way different
than 10 years ago is from now mhm the
acceleration of change and it's not
really constant acceleration of change
it's spurts and we are in the midst of a
spurt a punctuated
equilibrium and what's on the other side
of it I don't know man you know what all
I know is we're going to keep doing the
[__] that we do you know but it might
not be us I mean it's like one day it'll
just switch 10 years from now it it
won't be us we'll be listening to this
long 30 of GM G 30 of GMM will be fake
and y'all won't even know and we'll be
like on a beach
somewhere eat the beach will be on fire
eating a coconut and a
taco oh smile just smile let's whatever
we're ending with just put a smile on
your face I have a uh and we'll talk
what we'll do is we'll talk about you
remember how every couple of Seasons we
had to come up with what the intro was
going to be like what's the GMM theme
song version of the G M theme song this
year what's the new intro right now
again we're creative people and so we
may decide well there's joy in creating
the intro but we'll probably be like he
it's just another intro AI give me 15
different intros we'll choose the best
one and then we'll create something else
that's better than just another intro
right isn't that what will happen I
you're not going to stop creating but
I'm still I'm good we're still
good um I have something that is maybe
somewhat comfortable comforting good my
wreck uh I have
found a meditative dub inspired Jazz Duo
from
[Laughter]
Copenhagen your search your Search is
Over is
over and I've also think what I found is
in 2024 my favorite genre of music now
say it again Med ative dub inspired Jazz
from Copenhagen from like Scandinavia
area uh and I don't really know what dub
inspired is but it wasn't what I thought
that would be it's not has nothing to do
with like dub step it's just really
ethereal uh music that makes you feel
good and is super contemplative the way
so the band that I found is Brimmer SL
McCoy two guys Brimmer and McCoy
uh who've been making music for about 10
years
and every single song is pleasant and
good instrumental all
instrumental and you can put on like
Brimmer McCoy radio and it'll just send
you into that world of people like these
guys who make this type of music and you
can listen for hours and hours and hours
and it'll just you'll just it's very
pleasant but I what I would tell you to
do what I will tell you to do is uh just
just bring out their most recent album
noton n a ttn which sounds like it might
mean nothing in whatever language that
is Dutch I guess but
um sit down in a quiet room pull
yourself a little mug of tea or coffee
or whatever relaxes you and just don't
think about anything don't try to do
anything just listen to that album just
sit down in a comfortable place and
listen to nton until your son's alarm
clock goes off 6 feet deep in the back
you don't let the existential dread that
is in that is enclosing on every wall
around me
currently affect you uh just listen to
natson and remember that at the heart of
it all you're still just a human you're
still just you're just a piece of just a
meat bag maybe you want to send us a
voicemail that like makes us all feel
good we'll play it you know we need to
make up for what we've done here leave
us a voicemail 1888 earpod one and can I
make a a quick
promise let's hold ourselves back from
talking about this again for a while
okay check I understand that I'm that
guy that many of you don't
like because I am that guy it's hard for
you I know at the party app or your
friend group is like guys this is a [__]
you need to be thinking about and you
don't want to think about it I don't
want to think about it either and so I'm
going to say I'll keep thinking about it
but I'm not going to keep talking about
it until something else really
significant happens how about that nope
no no no no no no I'm not going to talk
about it for a while 2024 isn't going to
be the year where all R and Link talk
about is AI why don't you stop start
right now by stopping right now because
the thing that we're going to be talking
about doing it right now is we're going
to be creating things I'm so excited
about the things not that AI is going to
be making but the things that we are
going to be making the things that we're
working on right now that I've never
been more excited about what we're
creating yeah that's what I'm excited
about there you
go peace love and
happiness hey R link this is Noah from
Santa Barbara California this one's for
link I just wanted to say I took your
wreck and I got the silicone shower
scrubber and and just like you it has
revolutionized my shower experience I
recommended it to my friend and I
revolutionized his as well so thank you
for that
one